what are some of the keys to remember
for good historical storytelling well
when you're doing research for your
history genre there are some things you
need to remember and one of the things I
like to teach people is that a always do
it yourself sometimes you might pay
somebody to go look up information but
what they research is what they think is
important so it when you are writing
then from their research you're writing
the book from their eyes not your eyes
so even if you become rich and famous
and you are still doing historical
fiction you still need to do it yourself
because it's actually the research is
passion I found out this oh my you know
Harding lost the White White House China
China in a gambling debt I mean you
gotta be kidding me you know so then I
get involved in it and I go learn more
well maybe the one that did the research
didn't think that was important you know
so I'm only writing from their point of
view um the other thing is you've never
done researching ever I think I've given
some examples in previous discussion
here on why because you may come up with
something in your book that you need to
go back and research to make it
believable so you're never really done
you should always have more research
than you would use because in the
research you shouldn't worry about where
you're putting it don't research in an
eye to all use it in this job gather
your research and then your research
should be embedded as you write and you
won't use it on you're never finished
researching and now even if you didn't
want to do another book a story like
this you might do the same history in
another book and they'll still use the
research but in your facts you don't
know where they're going to go and you
should never research
it said and with the intent of where
you're going to put them because that
limits your you're researching and
that's why what I mean the research
should drive the plot I mean not the
basic plot I know what I want but things
that happen as you go through and the
things you say that's what I think
you